[Music]
so we've discussed this broader
principle of nations keeping promises
but what about making them in the first
place was it wrong to encourage ukraine
to sign the budapest memorandum
no i don't think at the time it was it
was wrong uh this was a time when the
ussr had just
had collapsed a few years earlier and it
was quite important to prevent
the proliferation of nuclear states
to uphold the npt regime
and to find new ways of enhancing
security and i think it's very important
to understand the context within which
this agreement was taken this was a time
when russia ukraine and the west were
all seen as sort of democratic partners
they all were led by democratic systems
they've been perfect of course
but uh there was very much the
perception that um you know with the end
of the cold war russia would become uh
sort of a true member of the western
community of nations and that was also
what the russian leadership was saying
we must remember very clearly how uh
president yeltsin and foreign minister
causative they very clearly talked about
russia becoming a member of the
civilized club of nations in the west
uh and i think it would be very risky to
think uh that uh for example uh ukraine
with nuclear weapons would have been
more stable maybe it would have
prevented an
operation by um
by russia in in in ukraine but you know
what what if we think that russia would
have operated uh regardless so you know
i think that it's very very risky i
think the problem with uh with a
memorandum uh was that it it you know
ask around us it doesn't create the kind
of commitment that we have for example
within nato with article five so it
gives them the right gives guarantors a
right to intervene but not this sort of
compelling necessity to intervene uh and
i think that's part of the problem and
as was mentioned by professor 9 i mean
the violator of the agreement was
actually
russia and not to other western european
nations that were the garand tools
yes let me come to you um domitella just
mentioned um in terms of the way that
the memorandum was set up um
it was always um vague
without any specific promises this kind
of agreement was it always going to
suffer this fate if so then was it wrong
to encourage ukraine to sign it
well i know that a lot of
ukrainians think it is i've been talking
to
some of the people i know and they said
no you know a lot of us think it was a
mistake
um
and i think this mindset that
russia is the aggressor and russia is
the aggressor at the moment russia and
china are the through you know are truly
building up to to a kind of power status
that should worry us all about you know
across africa the chinese
presences is unavoidable from street to
street and it is a kind of silent
colonialism based on economic power
so all of that is worrying
but at the same time
um you know i for example you know there
was always this assumption wasn't there
that the us for example would always
have a stable leader a president who
would who knew
what the dangers were of pressing the
button
then you get somebody like donald trump
and you begin to ask
was that wise to think that in these
western democracies there are enough
checks and balances
so that it's okay for them to build up a
nuclear arsenal but not okay for
um the lesser nations i mean these are
the big questions that are now being
asked and i think social media for all
its ills
has become a real platform for asking
some of the questions that
previous generations didn't ask
who made the rules who kept the rules
who broke the rules who broke the rules
with punishment and who broke the rules
without any consequences
and i think it is time to rethink
all of these power relations and who
holds the weaponry
joseph let me come to you on this um
same question
was it wrong to encourage ukraine to
sign the buddha's memorandum and you
heard what jasmine had said there and if
i tag on is part of the problem with the
memorandum the vagueness of its
provisions as domitilla has highlighted
from the point of view of the
countries at the time
uh you have to ask what was the
alternative
if you say well ukraine could have kept
it these nuclear weapons which were
basically the old soviet nuclear weapons
there are many technologists who say
they couldn't have maintained them a and
b
they were so dependent on
supply train chains and expertise from
moscow
that the russians might have taken them
physically anyway
so was it a big mistake by the
ukrainians as some ukrainians are
arguing today
i don't think so if we do this counter
factual and ask what might have happened
if they refuse to sign it i'm not sure
it's wrong the more intriguing question
to me in the counter factual
is if uh ukraine had not signed the
non-proliferation treaty and it
developed its own smaller more usable
nuclear weapons would it be capable of
deterring
russia
and
maybe but maybe not
you have to ask are there every ever
cases you can think of
where a
uh non-nuclear power has attacked the
nuclear power
and that happened when argentina
attacked britain and the falkland
islands so i don't know i think the
maybe the problem was ukraine believing
too much
in the
budapest agreement
but was the budapest agreement itself
a bad idea vague as it was
uh i think if you look at the counter
factual i suppose i suggested i don't
think so
tariq let me come to you on exactly the
same question was it a mistake was it
was it wrong to encourage ukraine to
sign a a vagus um budapest memorandum i
agree uh very strongly with joseph now
on this actually no i don't think it was
wrong i think the breakup of the soviet
union
uh led to all sorts of things but on the
nuclear question these were very
dangerous things i mean there were some
soviet generals selling nuclear missiles
to third parties
uh and the general view i think of any
rational
state was to cut their numbers down i
mean that it happened in the ukraine
rightly so i mean there's no way the
uh military of the former soviet union
would have left nuclear weapons
australian nuclear missiles in ukrainian
islands or kazakhstan and they did the
same thing in kazakhstan which is not
usually
discussed the west flatted
gaddafi in libya to giving up his
nuclear weapons of course that example
is not good because they then attacked
him and totally wrecked and destroyed
that country
but in any case i'm not in favor of
every single state getting nuclear
weapons the example though should come
from some of the european powers i mean
britain is barely a nuclear pride can't
do anything militarily without the
agreement of the united states france
says germany isn't japan isn't there's a
big queue of countries waiting to become
a nuclear powers and if small countries
acquire these weapons through fair means
of foul then the argument
for a massive increase in nuclear states
becomes
becomes irresistible but one more thing
if you permit me
i know the current mode
or propaganda
in the west is to blame the russians for
everything
i think a big mistake was made by the
russians by uh god which off in not
having a signed treaty
prior to the unification of germany
which settled some issues including the
neutrality
of the ukraine i mean the ukraine said
it would be neutral between the west and
russia that was in its constitution
until 2019.
uh why was this
this clause then removed from the
constitution
i think there was a big big pressure on
them and the other thing about the
ukraine that you have to remember is
it's not unified half the population to
very recently was very pro-russian
odessa
the big poor town in the ukraine
historic importance is predominantly a
russian town so it's a mixed business in
the ukraine it isn't just black and
white the population itself is divided
and thirdly
when
the russians were meant to be our
friends before they
argued for and got their own sovereignty
and did as they please basically
mimicking the united states
um
there was a huge crime committed by
putin and yeltsin before him
and that was the assault on chechnya the
chechens asked if x y z abc all these
little parts of the former soviet union
can be independence why not us
we're bigger than the baltic states in
some cases what's the problem and a huge
war was unleashed supported by tony
blair and bush i mean they actually
praised the russians and putin for doing
it at a time when grossly the capital of
chechnya was being raised to the ground
so please let's not have this
crap about international communities and
morality and freedom and democracy what
is basically the west port their
interests
russia and the crime big crime of
putin is not just the crimea it is
asserting russian sovereignty to put it
mildly that is uh what is going on
a final word to you on this one uh
domitilla wouldn't have made any
difference that the
budapest memorandum was more formal and
less fake and included the sort of
article 5 nato
assurances
i think that it will i mean the question
of ukraine's security orientation and
protection is very it's really very
complex and it really lies at the cracks
of european security at the moment
so i think that even if at the time
there would have been discussions of
further security guarantees by the worst
they would have raised similar questions
because at the time when this was signed
the fate of crimea was also sort of a
bit discussed and there were challenges
there from russia which at the time
didn't materialize
but russia was still negotiating with
ukraine the fate of the black sea fleet
which is based on sevastopol so it would
have been really not the right moment to
move further uh in terms of guarantees
but what is often forgotten is there is
an additional treaty that was signed in
1998 between uh the presidents of russia
and ukraine whereby they divided the
black sea fleet um though the lease of
sevastopol was granted to the russian uh
black sea fleet the parts that ended up
on russian and russia's hands and also
whereby russia recognized the
territorial integrity
of uh of uh ukraine so there were many
other instruments which allowed for
ukrainians to feel that their security
and international borders were not uh
under threat however i would argue that
today you know the west uh with the
threat that is seen is being posed by
russia's mobilization around ukraine's
borders is behaving
i think uh quite effectively it is
providing as i said military and
economic support
it is also reinforcing its commitment to
nato's eastern european uh partners and
allies uh it is trying to see if it can
uh find and negotiate a solution without
necessarily
uh compromising on key principles uh
around nato around nato security to its
eastern european allies around
the question of the open door policy uh
which cannot be changed under the threat
of russian military invasion and also
there is a readiness to negotiate on
issues which are of concern to both
sides around arms controls transparency
confidence building measures so i think
that uh you know at the moment the
position of the west uh i think i would
argue despite the difference of
approaches and the perception that
within europe there are different uh
views about how to deal with russia
especially around the energy question
and the north stream to gas pipeline i
think there is quite quite strong
cohesiveness and i think that uh
one cannot expect that uh you know
western or sort of american soldiers
would be sent to ukraine
uh and i think we're trading a very i
think sorry domitella you've uh
you've moved us into the third theme
which i probably should just introduce
properly and then and then and let's
develop this but just to wrap up where
we were on the second theme i think a
lot of the um
the panel i raised a range of issues
around what the circumstances were at
the time and i think as um
as we've just heard from domitella there
were other subsequent agreements um as
well so
it is uh as always uh the counterfactual
pose by joseph nye gives us the sense as
well as to um what uh the context um is
and i think tariq and jasmine raised
very good points
um around all of these issues which
actually brings us to the current day
so we've looked at the past the failings
the mistakes the judgments the
counterfactuals so
currently
we find ourselves in the situation
in the ukraine and the question um in
this final theme
should the west stick to their word and
seek to support ukraine if so must
involve military and
the military or are there threats of
economic sanctions enough
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas